[Applause]
the prime minister of course is in the
middle east his place being taken by
dominic ron
on behalf of my right honourable friend
the prime minister as the house will
know he's traveling in the united arab
emirates saudi arabia to discuss energy
security diplomatic action on russia and
ukraine and regional issues including
iran mr speaker with your forbearance
may i also say that i understand that
four members of the ukrainian parliament
are here with us in the gallery
and i'm sure i speak for the whole house
in saying that we stand in total
solidarity with you
camelot is one of the largest employers
in watford and for watford and its
employees have worked tirelessly to
successfully run the national lottery
for decades they play an important role
in communities across the uk many local
projects and good causes including in my
constituency so whilst i obviously
declare an interest in the gambling
commission's decision yesterday not to
appoint the license to camelot i do
wonder
given the current situation in ukraine
if my right honourable friend considered
it appropriate that the next licensee of
the operator of the national lottery is
known to have a joint venture with
gazprom
can i thank my honourable friend and
just say what a
an incredible job the national lottery
has done delivering 45 billion pounds to
good causes he's right the fourth
license will ensure
operator profits are better aligned with
returns to good causes can i just also
say on the specific points he makes i
understand that alwyn's owner mr komarak
who's long criticized the putin regime
is in discussions with the czech
republic government regarding the joint
venture with gazprom and removing its
involvement
we now come to the deputy leader of the
opposition angela reyna
thank you mr speaker and can i also
welcome ukrainian mps to this house
today and mr speaker can i start by
wholeheartedly welcoming the positive
steps towards returning nazideen sagari
radcliffe and anusha ashuri to the uk
i'm sure members across the house want
to show their support for their families
and them i know the minister would agree
that this devastating situation must
never be repeated and other british
nationals still trapped in iran need to
be brought home
so will the minister commit to a review
of these cases to understand
what more could have been done by the
british government to secure releases
and whether the lazy comments of the
prime minister worsened the situation
deputy prime minister
thank you mr speaker can i first of all
say that i can't yet confirm um the
reports we've seen in the media but of
course it feels like positive signs
and of course no one wants more than
me but i'm sure all members of the house
to see naznin but also all of the
arbitrarily detained nationals reunited
with their loved ones i can tell the
honorable lady having worked for two
years with the concerted diplomatic
effort led by the prime minister that we
have done absolutely everything that we
can she shouldn't give sucker to the
despotic regime
[Applause]
our nationals in iran or around the
world by suggesting it's anyone else's
responsibility other than that
[Applause]
mr speaker it's exactly for that reason
that i asked for the review that it's
important to learn from our mistakes so
we don't end up with other innocent
families facing this ordeal again so i
hope the minister will consider my
comments mr speaker
i'd like to thank all of the people who
have been working tirelessly to bring
british nationals home from iran our
diplomatic staff and our world leading
british intelligence agencies the role
of the british intelligence today is
critical in the face of putin's
aggression
the deputy prime minister oversaw our
foreign intelligence services as foreign
secretary so can he confirm
if at any time he overruled or ignored
direct advice from the british security
services
deputy prime minister can i say the
honourable ladies what she suggests is
nonsense uh she's talking about the
house of lords
appointments commission uh they have a
vetting process uh i have never
overruled uh intelligence advice and i
wouldn't comment on the details of it
what i would say and would agree with
her on the strength the agility of the
british diplomatic service which time
and time again
are the unsung heroes and returning
british nationals often less celebrated
cases than this but i think now is a
great opportunity to recognize the
heroic work they
do lorena absolutely i agree with the
minister regarding his comments on their
heroic work the right honourable member
was foreign secretary on the 17th of
march 2020 when british intelligence
reportedly warned against the granting
of peerage to the prime minister's close
friend and now lord lebedev of hampton
and siberia
48 hours later the prime minister
visited lebadev at his home in london
details of that meeting have never been
released
in july 2020
lebedev's appointment as peer was
announced so can he tell the house
what changed between the security
warning and the appointment
deputy prime minister sorry the
honorable lady knows full well all
individuals nominated for a period
you've done so in recognition of what
their contribution is to society
and and i should say
and i should say i should say
that includes those of russian origin
who contribute brilliantly to our nation
many of whom in this country are critics
of the putin
regime live peerages are vetted by the
house of lords appointments commission
uh for matters of probity and and
frankly i think she should know better
angela mr speaker what i do know better
is the central duty of any government is
to keep the british people safe
there are now widespread reports that
the prime minister did not accept
warnings from our own intelligence
services granting the russian oligarch
the son and business party partner of a
kgb spy a seat here in this parliament
it shouldn't matter if such a warning
was about a close personal friend of the
prime minister it shouldn't matter if he
gave the prime minister thousands of
pounds of gifts and it shouldn't matter
how much champagne and caviar he serves
there's no ifs or books when it comes to
the safety of the british people so i
asked the deputy prime minister
can he guarantee that the prime minister
never asked anyone to urge the security
services to revise
reconsider or withdraw their assessment
of lord lebedev of hampton and siberia
debbie prime minister the the suggestion
she's making is she nonsense
because she wants to talk about national
security then i remind her that she and
her shadow cabinet colleagues not so
long ago wanted the honourable member
for islington north
mr speaker a man who wanted and talked
about abolishing the army pulling out of
trident she voted for that has it ever
been a more ridiculous reckless naive
moment to call for unilateral nuclear
disarmament and pulling out of nato
labor a labor government would put at
risk our security within everything we
carry for protection
[Applause]
to nato and may i remind the deputy
prime minister that it was his prime
minister in 2015 that said wasn't he
wasn't sure if it was morally
irresponsible to work with putin so i
don't think he's on safe grounds there
last week mr speaker my right honourable
friend the leader of the opposition said
that britain should never again be at
the mercy of a foreign dictatorship for
our energy and fuel security
this week the prime minister has gone
cap in hand from one dictator to another
on a begging mission to the saudi prince
to bail him out
mr speaker the government about 12 years
to end their reliance on foreign oil and
invest in homegrown energy to secure our
supplies
their failure has left us all vulnerable
relying on another murderous dictator to
keep the lights on and pumps open
i'm going to hear this question if some
people don't what
somebody want to make
if you want a little argument i'm more
than happy because we can argue outside
when you're there
but for the moment i need to get on i
want to hear the question
answering
thank you mr speaker the government
benchers have a choice
they could accept labour's plan to save
working families hundreds of pounds on
bills funded with a one-off levy on the
soaring profits of big energy companies
so i asked the deputy prime minister
it's their only plan to keep on begging
deputy prime minister
what can i can i just um
uh
gently say to the honourable lady that
when she was campaigning as the rest of
them were to make the honourable member
for islington north prime minister
this prime minister
was foreign secretary
leading the response to the nerve agent
attacked
hate to say you can't keep going back
for 12 years as a defensive mechanism
what we want to do
i'll decide thank you
what i want you to do deputy prime
minister please so we can try and stick
to the generals have a lot of people
ahead of it who are desperate to get in
without talking about history how far
we're going to go back it's one thing in
passing deputy prime minister thank you
mr speaker um
when when she was or otter
so desmond
he is not responsible for the
opposition's policies this is about the
government this is about questions to
the deputy prime minister i'll put the
questions and decide to write deputy
prime minister thank you uh mr speaker i
was uh wanted just to point out and i
hope it's not uh ancient history that
the prime minister was as foreign
secretary galvanizing the response to
the nerve agent attack in salisbury at
the time where the honourable member the
former leader of the labour party
was was siding with putin against the uk
what did the honourable lady we're just
breaking into prime minister's questions
for a bit of breaking news about
nazaneen zagari radcliffe this is coming
from the reuters news agency they are
quoting iran's judiciary who have
confirmed to them the release of the
british iranian nazanin zagari radcliffe
after years of detention so this is
coming from reuters this is not
confirmed by us independently at sky
news and we haven't had confirmation yet
from the british government but reuters
are quoting iran's judiciary as saying
that nazanin zagari radcliffe has been
released after years of detention
we'll bring you any more confirmation on
this
let's return to the comments the right
thing for british diplomacy and provide
security for the british people
instead mr speaker we have this sorry
excuse of the government sat before us
they hiked
20 they had tax on 27 million working
people while the super rich increase
their wealth they watch energy prices
rise by over 50 percent while the
companies enjoy profits they didn't even
expect and they could vote with russian
oligarchs in luxury villas while
neglecting the security of the british
people and remember mr speaker
they parted while their country was in
lockdown and were unable to see their
dying loved ones can the deputy prime
minister lock the british people in the
eye and really say this government is
doing their best in their interest
well mr speaker i'll tell you what this
government this prime minister have done
a thousand russian individuals uh
sanctioned a combined wealth 45 billion
uh dollars the impact of the sanctions
and the diplomatic effort that this
foreign secretary and this prime
minister have led the ruble plummeting
the russian stock market at record lows
double the interest rates we've also
showed we've also showed
we've also showed mr speaker the
big-hearted spirit of this government
and indeed this nation with the 5 500
visas granted to ukrainians to come here
and also the humanitarian route which
has now got uh a hundred thousand
sponsors applying to come uh to take
ukrainian families in these homes while
she's in her social media echo chamber
that's what this government
thank you mr speaker it was very good to
see my right honourable friend visit the
international criminal court earlier
this week but they have enduring
difficulties with funding last year they
had a 40 million dollar shortfall in
their budget because some participating
states failed to meet their annual
contribution the international criminal
court is only as good as the sum of its
parts so what steps can the government
take to secure contingency funding to
ensure that one day russian military
commanders in ukraine can expect to
stand trial for war crimes
[Applause]
[Music]
the assembly estates party is looking at
the arrears i was in the hague on monday
speaking to the prosecutor and the
president of the court we will be coming
forward with a voluntary package of
financial and technical support because
now as they look at the situation in
ukraine we want and i think the whole
house would want putin is commanded to
know if they continue with war crimes in
ukraine they'll end up not just in the
dock of a court but behind bars
we don't come to the leader of the smp
in blackfoot
thank you mr speaker can i welcome our
four colleagues from the parliament of
ukraine who are with us today we all
stand with them
mr speaker
i've spent much of the last week
trying to help the scottish charity
nepal kids established by fans of
hibernian football club who've evacuated
48 children from orphanages in ukraine
and are desperately attempting to
provide them with temporary sanctuary in
scotland
mr speaker
there is a plane ready and waiting in
poland
to bring these orphans to the uk on
friday
but that flight will leave empty without
the necessary paperwork from the home
office
the polish authorities edinburgh city
council the scottish government and the
orphans guardians are all working
to bring these children to safety
i work with uk government ministers to
try and make this happen and i want to
commend lord harrington in particular
for his efforts
but a week on
the home office is still proving to be
the only obstacle in the way and it
risks leaving these children stranded
so i'm pleading
with the deputy prime minister
remove these obstructions before it's
too late will he work with me
and the ukrainian authorities to
guarantee
that these 48 ukrainian orphans will get
on that plane
this friday yeah
the prime minister can i thank the
honourable gentleman for all he's doing
this is a heart-rending uh situation we
want to do everything we can
of course
there are a range of issues in this case
including the wishes of the ukrainian
government on where orphaned children
should go and should be living whether
any necessary permissions have been
sought from the ukrainian and or polish
governments this isn't uh actually about
bureaucracy it's about genuine
safeguarding issues but i certainly want
to work with him in the best interests
of those children
ian
i'm asking the government to do just
exactly that because we've been working
with the ukrainian and polish
authorities we have their support we
need the home office to give us the
paperwork that'll make that happen
because mr speaker
this one case goes to the heart of the
failure in the uk government's response
to the biggest refugee crisis in europe
since world war ii
it is deeply
concerning that it's taken the
intervention of several ministers of
state letters to multiple european
ambassadors and the fear of this case
being exposed in the chamber to try and
force movement in an urgent case
involving almost 50 vulnerable children
even whether it is the will it seems
that simply there is no way that the
home office can get involved i shouldn't
have been sending letters to the
authorities in ukraine and poland the
home office should have been doing it
if all these powerful people can't make
it happen
what hope do all the other children
fleeing this awful war have a finding
sanctuary in the uk
the united nations
are now estimating that almost one child
a second is becoming a refugee from the
war in ukraine these 48 children will
not be the last who needs sanctuary and
safety surely the deputy prime minister
agrees it shouldn't have taken this
level of intervention and pressure for
the home office to do the right thing by
these two
minister well can i just say to me it's
very important that the proper
international practices on safeguarding
follow i know i know he appreciates that
we're keen to find out if family reunion
options with ukrainian family in the
region have been considered we also know
can can you just listen for a second
because it's important
we also know that many children in state
care in ukraine have family members in
the region for safeguarding and
wellbeing of the children that must also
be considered
more broadly he raises the issue about
refugees and children on top of the
measures that i've already mentioned
we're making plans for the arrival of a
hundred thousand ukrainian children uh
through the education secretary in our
schools and i pay tribute to their
health secretary for bringing ukrainian
children suffering from cancer over to
this country to receive the vital
treatment
british servicemen and women have served
under operations cabrit and orbital
since 2015 working with ukrainian armed
forces and helping to shore up the
eastern flank of nato which is now more
important than ever
would the deputy prime minister join
with me and putting on the record the
gratitude of this house and consider
what recognition we can give them for
their service and for their role in
history
she's absolutely right she's uh totally
right to pay tribute to the
professionalism the dedication the
sacrifice of our uh armed service men
and women every day to defend this
country
she'll know that recognition for all
military operations is kept under
continuous review and i know that the
defense secretary will have heard her
very compelling suggestions stephen
thank you mr speaker can i first of all
wish you and the entire house and early
happy patrick's day
[Applause]
um
the there was a 3.1 increase to
universal credit and other benefits set
by the government last september but
inflation is now pushing a seven percent
the joseph raunchy foundation trustworth
and many other organizations have
highlighted the real jeopardy that
millions of people are now facing from a
real terms cut in the level of benefits
another measures from the government
simply don't compensate for that so
surely it's not terrible for the
government to stick so rigorously to a
decision taken six months ago whenever
circumstances have changed so radically
since then
prime minister can i thank the
honourable gentleman look he's right
about the cost of living challenge not
least with the war in ukraine the
government and the chancellor have
already put in place a 20 billion pound
package across this year 9 billion
pounds to help with energy bills the the
rest to deal with the wider cost of
living issues that includes raising the
national living wage on uc that he
mentions we're giving nearly two million
families an extra thousand pounds a year
the kickstart
scheme the increasing the personal uh
tax threshold by over 50 since 2010
we're doing everything we can of course
we'll keep the cost of living issues
under constant and regular review growth
davis
thank you mr speaker with multinational
scaling back russian operations and
local businesses stepping forward with
offers of jobs and equipment once again
british businesses are responding at a
time of great challenge
will the deputy prime minister join me
in thanking all those businesses across
lincolnshire who have offered support
and can he outline how the government
may be able to connect those offers of
support with the ukrainians in mostly
prime minister i thank my honourable
friend and i do join him in thanking all
those businesses but also the charities
and the individual families up and down
the country who have shown the
big hearted uh traditions that make this
country so great um
he will be aware of course of the new
sponsorship scheme uh we've had overall
a hundred thousand sponsors apply and of
course working with businesses is
particularly valuable because we know
that there's huge value not just in
terms of allowing those that come here
to get access to work but it also helps
them to integrate into our society as
confident members of our community matt
weston
thank you thank you mr speaker i'm sure
the deputy prime minister will agree
with me that when it comes to judging a
person um it's often done by the company
that they keep
when it comes to uh when it comes to
tennis
when it when it comes to tennis the
prime minister enjoys the company of
and back handles of newborn chernikov
when it came to celebrating the election
victory the prime minister prioritized
the party hosted by the former kgb agent
alexander lebedev he has a great many
others such as viktor peditov and
alex tomerico as friends
can he therefore tell us
uh what first attracted the prime
minister
to the billionaire russian oligarchs
i wasn't quite sure where he was going
at the beginning of this question but
what i can tell him of course the prime
minister is not just
a very social individual he
[Applause]
he wants this country
he wants his country to be open outward
looking to the world but we have we were
the government and he was the prime
minister and i was the foreign secretary
that introduced the sergei magnitsky
sanctions that put
human rights sanctions asset freeze and
visa bans not just on uh russians uh
where we have evidence of wrongdoing but
also the the murderers of khashoggi also
the uh the persecutors of the myanmar uh
uh minority uh and many others it was
this government uh not the labour party
aria baldwin yeah
thank you mr speaker
the eyes of the world are rightly
focused on putin's evil invasion of
ukraine
but there is still a humanitarian crisis
in afghanistan and i welcome the fact
that the uk government is hosting a
pledging conference later this month for
that crisis
and can my right honourable friend
ensure that we also keep education for
those poor children on the agenda yeah
deputy prime minister she's absolutely
right and we will keep the focus on
afghanistan and the many other conflicts
around the world that need our support i
can tell her that that particular
conference will provide specifically
support for access to girls education a
long-standing priority of the prime
minister and i would also just point out
that we've doubled our humanitarian aid
to afghanistan for the financial year to
286 million pounds
thank you mr speaker
appeasing murderous despots is never
going to be the route to security of
energy supply so wouldn't it make more
sense for the prime minister to be here
talking to uk energy industries
shouldn't he be talking to renewable
energy developers about what they can do
to bring their product on stream faster
and quicker and shouldn't he also be
speaking to our own offshore oil and gas
industry about what they can do
in the here and now to improve security
of supply and to assist in the journey
towards net zero
yes he was doing that on monday evening
i can uh tell the honourable gentleman
and now it's wednesday and yes he's out
in saudi arabia uh closing a one billion
pound investment deal creating 700 jobs
in the north in renewable energy i think
the lib dems need to keep up
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker north norfolk is a
rural constituency and many residents
rely on their car to get around and they
heat their homes by using heating oil
the price of crude oil may have come
down in the last few days but the petrol
pumps are still going up and i've had
constituents who are quoted two pounds a
liter for heating oil this not only
affects working families but pensioners
in rural areas who are on a fixed income
can i ask that the deputy prime minister
does everything he can to make sure that
in the spring statement we address these
problems for really really rural
constituencies that are getting the
double whammy of these crippling
commerces
[Music]
my honourable friend's absolutely right
uh he knows that we've got a 20 billion
pound package this year dealing with the
cost of living 9 billion of it focused
on energy prices the uh issues that he
talks about for uh his constituency but
i think up and down the country are i
think very well made and i know the
chancellor will have heard his uh his
suggestions jeff smith
thank you mr speaker the prime
minister's visiting saudi arabia and as
usual we are told there will be frank
private discussions with the saudis on
their human rights record but in the
light of the state murder of jamal
khashoggi in the light of the brutal
executions of 81 men at the weekend
why does the deputy prime minister think
that the uk's representations on human
rights are so ineffective and what more
will we do
to make the saudis behave ethically yeah
thank you gentlemen
can i just say to him when i was foreign
secretary and i went to riyadh twice i
know the prime minister will be raising
these issues again we talked about the
women's rights defenders he says we've
been effective ineffective they've all
been released we talked about ralph
badawi the author and critic he was
recently released he mentions jamal
khashoggi we applied i think one of the
first to apply asset freeze and visa
bans on those responsible for his murder
so we are an outward uh uh an
international country that is what
britain's role is in the 21st century
but we will never uh we will never allow
our moral red lines to be blurred tom
thank you very much mr speaker um
once said about the polish people you
may swallow the pole but you will never
digest them i think that powerful quote
says so much for how the polish people
have stood up robustly and strongly
against aggression over the years and
also about their steadfast support right
now for their close and dear allies the
ukrainian people in ipswich we've had
three lorries go from ipswich to levitt
in support of ukrainian people will the
deputy prime minister outline the steps
of government to take to support our
close allies poland as they take an
unprecedented number of refugees and of
course whilst they have their own
security concerns in relation to russia
[Applause]
[Music]
he's absolutely right and i pay tribute
to
not just his constituents but the polish
community in particular and of course uh
for their big-hearted um uh support for
the people of ukraine and of course uh
as a leading donor i think the second
largest donor to ukraine we've committed
a further 174 million pounds in aid
bring our total to 400 million pounds
but that will also support those
countries in the uh close proximity to
ukraine their neighbours and first and
foremost will be poland
justin
mothers speaker on the 28th of april
2018 when he was foreign secretary the
prime minister is reported to have
attended a party at a castle in italy
where he met a former kgb officer now
this was just weeks after the salisbury
poisonings and immediately after he
attended a nato summit on russia if that
is not astonishing enough in itself it
is also reported he traveled there
without any security detail or officials
presence so will there now be an
investigation into what sounds like a
complete failure of national security
[Applause]
in addition
to my constituents concerns
the ukraine
they're also concerned about planning
policy
i wrote to the prime minister in october
2019
about the threats of the goring gap
it's against government policy it's
against public interest for every green
field that's a strategic gap to be built
on
and inspectors made a decision which
would wipe away the planning powers of
every local council in the country can i
ask if the prime minister will see me
and if the government will revoke this
inspector's mistaken decision
can i thank him
can i also i mean i empathize with
someone with a massive uh proportion of
agreement my constituency on the uh the
frustrations i think honourable members
across the house feel uh with some uh
planning decisions that that are made
however once a planning decision is
final um it can't be challenged unless
it's successfully challenged in the
courts
stephanie peacock thank you mr speaker
last year
255 children and young people were
admitted to barnes hospital for
self-harm that is 15 times the national
average this is a public health crisis
so will the deputy prime minister ask
the health secretary to meet with me and
health care providers from balancing to
immediately respond to this mental
health crisis
we've had a huge amount uh into both
mental health
and wider
the nhs budget not just on code to
respond to the wider issues i will
certainly make sure in relation to the
specific issue that she raises that an
appropriate health minister will see her
dr julian lewis
are any oligarchs with uk passports on
our sanctions list
can i thank the chair of the isc i think
i would have to let the foreign
secretary in the foreign office check
carefully and respond to him in due
course
stephen
thank you thank you mr speaker three
weeks ago the chair of the uk statistics
authority sir david norgrove wrote to
the prime minister to point out that his
repeated assertion that employment is
now higher than it was before the
pandemic is incorrect yesterday's
employment statistics show 840 000 fewer
self-employed people now than before the
pandemic and that overall employment is
580 000 lower does the deputy prime
minister agree that truthfulness is
vital to trust in our democracy does he
accept the correction from sir david
norgrove
look of course we listen very carefully
to
today
but what i would say to the honourable
gentleman is actually he points the data
yesterday it showed that unemployment
has fallen below four percent is back is
back at pre-pandemic levels and has been
termed a remarkable success uh from
everyone to the resolution foundation he
talks about the truth there's one golden
truth and that is uh whenever there is a
labor government in the past
unemployment has always been higher
when they left office when they started
mr speaker that's the jobs guarantee you
get with labour
thank you mr speaker
thank you mr speaker we have now
provided more than 3 000 anti-tank
weapons training and other military
support to ukraine
alongside crushing financial sanctions
on russia and more bilateral assistance
humanitarian assistance aid than any
other country yeah but can my rental
friend confirm that we will continue to
deliver further military aid and support
and with that we will supply the star
streak anti-aircraft missiles necessary
to destroy russian jets
is absolutely right we've delivered uh
over 3600 anti-tank missiles uh weapons
uh we'll also be sending consignment of
the javelin anti-tank missiles and we
are indeed as it says exploring the
donation of star street anti-air
missiles
thank you mr speaker it's welcome that
ukrainians seeking asylum in britain
will have the right to work and access
to public services we should always
offer sanctuary to those fleeing
persecution
people who come to britain to make it
their home no matter where they're from
or the colour of their skin make a
hugely
positive contribution to our society and
economy if they're supported to do so so
how can the government now justify not
extending the same welcome and the same
rights including the right to work to
all people seeking asylum in britain
the prime minister he's right that we
have a strong tradition and we've shown
we've stepped up to the plate with the
hong kong british national overseas
citizens with operation pitting which
brought 17 000 back and we will go
further beyond the normal rules when
there is a crisis as we've seen in
ukraine he's absolutely right about what
he uh said in relation to the current
scheme they those coming here the
ukrainians can live work and access
benefits they can stay for three years
with leave to remain and i'm proud and
the whole house should be proud not just
of the big hearted approach of this
government but also the hundred thousand
british sponsors who've come forward and
said they will open their homes to those
refugees serene duncan smith uh mr
speaker can i ask my right old friend
that as the brilliant ukrainian people
fight and die on a daily basis for their
rights of freedom and democracy
it's important therefore that we make
something very clear and i wonder if he
would do this
they have asked for membership of nato
for a significant period of time and
nato has chosen not to give it to them
my concern now is no matter what they
decide
it remains their absolute right as a
free nation and a free people
to make such an application in the
future and noticing that finland is
talking about being a member that we
treat them in exactly the same way as we
would an application from finland
can i thank my right honourable friend i
mean you will have heard what uh
president zielinski has said overnight
in relation to this but one of the
things that we've always been crystal
clear as a government is that if there
is a diplomatic off-ramp and i have to
say we have a heavy measure of
skepticism about whether putin could
ever fulfill such a deal but if there is
it has to be done with the will and the
volition of the ukrainian president and
the ukrainian people
we now come to karumana thank you mr
speaker my constituent is a popular
parish priest in glasgow originally from
nigeria he became a british citizen last
year and applied for his first british
passport last summer
on his naturalization certificate issued
by the home secretary it includes his
title rather reverend father under his
name this is causing the passport office
unexplained difficulties and seven
months on he's still waiting for his
passport can ask the deputy prime
minister to look at this case as a
matter of urgency his mother is
extremely ill in nigeria he needs to get
his passport to visit her
deputy prime minister can i thank the
honourable lady for raising that case it
sounds very sensitive i will make sure a
home office minister looks at it as a
matter of urgency
that finishes questions
i'll just let the room clear and then
i'll do it
well prime minister's questions there uh
touching on events in ukraine uh
russia's uh links to some in the
conservative party uh including lord
lebedev uh and also the subject of
refugees brought up also touched on uh
the fate of nazanin zagari radcliffe
although the deputy prime minister
dominic raab unable to confirm anything
further than what we already know this
morning uh let's bring in our political
editor beth rugby is in wesleyan so
dominic grab and angela rainer taking uh
the uh steps there today uh because the
prime minister is away in the middle
east um what are you able to tell us
about the breaking news that we have
about the potential race of of nazaneen
zagari radcliffe today
well the latest we have jane is that uh
nazanin has been released and is at the
airport there have been some reports
that she has left the country we haven't
been able to confirm that in fact a
source told me that that wasn't
correct so we're not going to go any
further than we already have done which
is that we think she's been released and
we're waiting uh for information as to
when she could be flying home obviously
this is an enormous
moment for richard her husband who has
campaigned relentlessly to get his wife
nazarine released she's been imprisoned
for nearly six years and she also has
her daughter gabriella
at home in london waiting for her mum to
come home obviously a huge moment too
for tulip sadiq
richard and nazanin's local mp who has
also worked tirelessly to try to get her
release so this is really an enormous
moment and a happy news story uh admits
such terrible news at the moment over
ukraine
indeed and also uh for liz truss um the
foreign secretary if feather and her cap
if this does indeed prove to be true
that's right jane and actually tulip
sadiq uh was saying only earlier on the
airwaves uh there are a number of
foreign secretaries she mentioned uh mr
johnson boris johnson the former foreign
secretary jeremy hunt philip hammond
that weren't able to get nazzanin
released but it seems like liz trust has
broken this deal it has as i understand
been some months in the making and
the local iranian news agencies have
reported
that the uk government has released 530
million dollars that's 405
million pounds an old
debt that was owed by the uk government
it was related to
a purchase of tanks that were not
delivered by the uk government back in
1979
that the agencies in iran are reporting
that the british government have
released that money so that money has uh
gone uh in return uh for nazanin and
also anu ashori she is another detainee
uh that has been released but i have to
say the uk government have not yet
confirmed that we are waiting to hear
from them so we're all really on tender
hooks to find out when nazanin is
actually able to leave tehran
okay beth thanks very much for bringing
us the latest
on the political side our political
editor beth reaping there well also
joining me now is dr roxanne farman
farmayan who's a lecturer in
international relations at the middle
east at the university of cambridge uh
good to get your thoughts today why do
you think this has happened at this
particular point
i think that the first of all such a ray
of good news and um i think it it
possibly
is a harbinger of further good news uh
in that it seems that the transfer of
funds that have taken place
has actually been an unblocking of funds
and this means perhaps that the
arrangements that have been in process
for the iran deal are themselves coming
to a head and may indeed lead to some
positive news in the future in the near
future so i am hoping that this is the
first of a couple of pieces of good news
but it is excellent that
that it's now zaneen and uh possibly
anushay um ashuri that are also being
released uh at this time
and in terms of that iran nuclear deal
just just remind our